we want to get to our dr. David agus who
joins us from Los Angeles to talk about
possible treatments for the virus doctor
good morning we're all so hungry right
now for any kind of good news the
president wants to fast-track a drug
used to treat malaria for application to
coronavirus what more can you tell us
about that is it promising well there
are two drugs chloroquine and hydroxy
Clerkin that are approved that are on
the market and I can write a
prescription for today in fact I have
over the last several weeks and they
certainly seem in pilot studies to have
an effect on the virus and hopefully to
make people do better so this is real
hope with these two drugs and they're
here and we're using them and so in its
optimism and I was very excited that the
president took that step forward
yesterday I want and pushing him to go
further and actually say use it early
use it in people who were exposed
because we have to stop the spread of
this virus so these could be
preventative drugs
David well right now their treatment
their treatment with significant disease
you know the problem is is that when you
come to see me I do your tests it may be
three four or five days till I get it
back and what we know with these drugs
is the earlier you use them the better
so again I think people should be
treated with them when we think they
have the virus and then if you're a
first responder if you're a doctor a
nurse a healthcare professional and you
take care of a patient who's spreading
the virus maybe you should take them to
prevent the spread those studies are
ongoing but we in the field cannot wait
for those studies and now we have
optimism with real drugs that are here
today so David at what point do you give
these drugs to someone who's been
infected and do you have concerns about
fast-tracking these drugs again I don't
even know what the word fast-tracking me
the drugs are available they're here
today so you may fast-track their FDA
approval but I don't care if they're FDA
approved or not we are using them and so
we're using them as early as possible in
patients with this disease and this is
doctors across the country are talking
about it and using them and we've been
doing so for several weeks but obviously
when the president endorses that yes
trade use is going to go up I like it
with dr. David agus has real hope yes I
like back to dr. David agus David thank
you